[Musique]
voilà et cartons dont un peu pour voir
le résultat
c'est bon en tout cas pour une fois mon
kiosque et bien rangé c'est grâce à tous
acabits s'est fait alors je peux être
fier de moi bien sûr
or je vais tout de suite avec le dire à
ma tante adélaïde tu as raison pendant
ce temps je vais te chercher un beau
cadeau pour te remercie je lis pas tout
à leur rêve
je suis fier de moi je suis fier de moi
monsieur mais comme vous voulez vous
notre cher ami permettez moi tout
d'abord de vous saluer messieurs 10 noms
que vous m'avez fait peur comment vous
m'avez reconnu bien sûr vous êtes le
seul dans l'îlot z'enfants rappelé ma
très chère julie au suis chaud au cul
liège pensé oh j'aurais dû évidemment
employer un langage plus populaires
enfin je ne la prenaient pourtant
comment trouvez vous ma tenue de
motocyclistes après j'ai mis ce n'est ce
pas c'est la dernière mode sur les
circuits de moto vous allez faire une
course de moto comment vous ne le saviez
pas bonjour monsieur je vois c'est
françois qui n'a pas voulu le dire de
peur de vous effrayer françois fait
cette course lui aussi oui mes chers
amis nous sommes les deux seuls
concurrents
c'est un défi entre lui et moi une
courte ou de lille
d'ailleurs le départ doit avoir lieu
dans moins d'une heure et vous n'avez
moto ni l'un ni l'autre
il m'a très cher mais cela fait partie
aussi le défi que nous nous sommes
lancés hier nous avions une journée
entière pour trouver une moto afin
d'être au départ de la course et vous
allez retrouver une merveille un petit
bijou de la technique
je les trouvais chez monsieur beauchesne
il l'avait acheté pour ses 20 ans et
bien messieurs vos chaînes est presque
un vieux monsieur
oui mais la moto elle est en très bon
état well as juste un peu de crever j'ai
commandé une chambre à air le facteur
dans mais la portée d'un moment à
l'autre
je serai fin prêt là bas vous avez
beaucoup de chance monsieur du snap
parce que moi je crois bien que j'y
arriverai jamais
mais françois comment t'es-tu mis dans
cet état bon j'ai pas eu la chance de
monsieur du snob et donc j'ai trouvé que
des vieilles motos tout cas c'est alors
j'essaie d'en être une en état de marche
avec les meilleures pièces
ça n'a pas l'air facile au lalano ça me
paraît même impossible je suis désolé
pour vous mon pauvre ami et dans moins
d'une heure je prendrais seul le départ
autour d'elle et je serai le vainqueur
bonjour ensuite publié un article dans
le journal afin de célébrer ma victoire
mais monsieur du jeûne observé pas juste
françois n'a pas trouvé une moto un état
comme la voûte où tu suis désolé mon
cher ami blessé c'est la loi des paris
toutefois pour montrer ma sportivité
je veux bien les défenseurs dans la
mesure où je n'aurai pas à me salir sans
vous savez franchement monsieur dix neuf
ça me paraît pas très facile enfin venez
civile et oui c'est bien moi j'y vais
aussi oh oh là là je suis épuisé
monsieur du jeune homme a fait courir
sur le soleil pour lui apporter sa
chambre à air j'en peux plus mais comme
il m'a dit de la portée ici mais je vais
l'attendre tiens julie julie tu as mon
cadeau elle n'est pas là le mois là oh
oui c'est sûrement ça bonjour factor il
dort je ne vais pas faire de bruit au
une chambre r tout neuf
julie est vraiment gentille elle sac
avec de la crème chantilly c'est mon
dessert préféré
voilà un couteau
je vais ouvrir en deux voilà il ya même
de la crème chantilly
c'est formidable jeu je vais la remplir
je vais la remplir de crème et je
laverai d'un seul coup comment macaronis
en l'aspirant au je sais que c'est très
mal élevé mais personne ne me regarde et
bien tant pis tenté mais c'est dès ce 9
jeux seraient vaincus machines sont
d'une saleté
dommage il n'est pas manqué que quelques
boulons et oui mais voilà voici le
facteur je vais monter ma chambre à air
et je serai le vainqueur or c'est vous
monsieur les chenaux dit oui c'est moi
je n'avais pas vu je m'étais assoupi à
petit moment mais j'ai votre rêve enfin
c'est vrai vous l'exposez les jeunes je
l'avais posé là mais que voulez-vous
dire mais la wii la chambre et wafa
personne n'a pu la rose regardez ce que
moche casimir chambre a perdu
enfin casimir pourquoi tu fais ça
mais enfin je lis je croyais que c'était
mon cadeau tu sais bien qu'en une
chambre dans la crème chantilly c'est
mon dessert préféré c'est vrai qu il ya
eu un malentendu
personne ne vient il n'y aura pas de
vainqueur du défi
merci casino
à
[Musique]